やべ緊張するな
いきます
え、怖っまじで
まぁ今のところ大丈夫
え、怖いまじ怖い本当に怖い
本当に怖い怖いよー
怖い、怖い怖い　ライトつけます
うわぁ！
あれ？思ったより居ない、まさか
ゴールデンタイム
待ってわからんぞどこに何が潜んでるかわからんからな
いや、意外と大丈夫そうだ
おいおいおいおい！
お、おいおいおい
うわっおっおいおい
うわっ
あぁあー
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
あの…東京の家に何日ぶりくらいにきたかな
うわ
はい、というわけであのかなり久しぶりに
東京のおうちに来たところ
食べ物とかを残す僕よくない癖があるですよ
そして掃除をしない
ﾌﾝｯ いるよね
なかなかねビデオカメラだと見せづらいと思うんですけども
あのー部屋の中がもう小バエだらけなんですよ
割と世界有数レベルで今小バエが飛んでるんじゃないかなーと思いまして
今わざと東京に来ても寝れない
もう本当に大変なことになってるんですけども
とりあえず僕今日は泊まんないんですよ
明日朝が早いんでこのまま横浜のホテルまで行って
横浜で泊まるんで今日はこの家にいないんですけど
そしてこの後髪の毛切りに行って来ます
えへ(♪-∀-)
もうこのボサボサヘアーともさよならだぜ
Yeah foo!
僕がいない1日の間にあのコバエホイホイ
今日バカにみたいに買って来ました　カモン！
ホイ　ホイ　ホホイ　ホイ　ホイ　ホイ　ホイ
ガタッ　あーー！
ホイ　ホイ！
どうだい？小バエもビックリするくらいの量の
コバエホイホイを準備しました
多分これぐらいあってもちょっと足りないぐらいかもしれない
もう本当にビビるぐらい小バエが多すぎて
うわあぁ”あ”あ”ぁ”ぁ”うぁぁ
というわけでもうなんかもうちょっと本当に
目も開けれないくらい小バエが多いんすよ
実際伝わんないかなー
というわけでちょっとこの小バエのありえない数をなんとかするために
コバエホイホイを22個買ったので
ちょっとこれを部屋中にセットして
一晩おいてどれくらいの小バエを捕獲できるのか
ちょっと見てみたいと思います
Open !
うぅ
トン　トン　トトトン　トン
わ”ぁ”
ぁーもう！ほんとすごいよ
コバエホイホイの説明書読んでたら
ここに小バエ乗って来ますからね
いや、やべーよ小バエの数　あっち行けー
ﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯ
おーい
ﾀﾝｯ
はぁいっ
このゼリーの匂いでおびき寄せて
もう出れなくしてもうそのままキルするらしいです
面白いんだよねめっちゃ置いてる横に
もう小バエがここにいるっていうね
果たして俺が数ヶ月溜め込んだ汚さで
湧いて来てしまった小バエたちを
この大量のコバエホイホイでどれだけ退治できるのか
1日かけておいてみましょう　では
はい、というわけで帰って来ました
約一晩経ったのでちょっとどれくらい捕まってるか
すごい気になっているとこであります
見ていきましょーー!
え、待って怖いよー本当に怖い
さぁ
小バエたちは
震えて眠れ!!!
え？どうなってんの
うわ　あぁ　ああ　ああ！
待って、とりあえず開けましょう
一回全部開けさせていただきます
中以外にもめっちゃ倒れている子たちがいますね
うわぁうわあー　うわすげー
はい、というわけで周辺で倒れている方たちも含めて
全体で何匹ポックリできたのかちょっと数えてみます
108、109
いや、どんだけいるの
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
こん中とかもう見る限り
一箱に10匹以上捕まってますからね
いや、もう間違いなくなんか1個でやるよりかは
効果は絶対あったと思います
コバエホイホイ大量設置は結構効果的ということがわかりました
よかったら是非やってみてください
ちゃんと掃除しよ